what's up my name's samuel lee's i'm a
property investor i've been investing in
property now for over a decade
and every single week i always introduce
you to one of my success students
who's become financially free by
investing in property and often these
people have been in the game
for like six months sometimes even less
and people think how on earth do they
become financially free so quickly but
here's the thing
it can sometimes take a little bit of
time so i'm going to introduce you in a
moment to nicola black
and nicola is on the property investors
academy and
it took her two years to become
financially independent
now she's quit her full-time job and
she's doing property full-time but she's
even systemized the property business so
she's spending time now on health and
doing what she really feels passionate
about and loves
so you're gonna learn a whole bunch of
nuggets from this interview
listen take good notes also if you're
not already subscribed to the youtube
channel subscribe
smash the like button i look forward to
you enjoying this interview let me know
your comments in the comment section
below
so this is the first winners wednesday
i've ever done in this neck of the woods
i've i've come to you
mm-hmm normally people come to me thank
you and you are very far away from my
house
but i'm here what did you think of my
house that we just looked at
my worst house ever and i tried to sell
it to you but you were not buying it
because you've been taught well
um nicola great to have you on on the
show thank you so much it's been a long
time coming
um why don't you just give us a little
bit of backstory as to
when we met what you were doing what
life was like
uh right so i guess the journey started
when i
first discovered your book on amazon by
law went high
um ready at the time i was working
in the corporate world working for ee
i'd been there
probably about 15 years at the time i
had a very good job
very secure but i read your book
and something clicked something changed
that
made me kind of question whether or not
that was
the future i wanted to continue to
follow on it just
gave me a kind of different way of
thinking i've always been into property
i've developed a lot of my own houses
but i never considered i could actually
do it and make money from it so
that was probably the catalyst um your
book
so prior to that then you say you've
always been into property so do you mean
properties that you'd lived in my own
properties
right so you bought property and you you
kind of like fixed it
yeah it was just a little hobby i
enjoyed doing it yeah
and then you read my book and what was
it that you questioned you said that you
started looking at things a little bit
differently
just this i don't think i'd ever really
considered
that you could actually make a full-time
living out property that easily
you know i only knew probably the
traditional ways of you know buy a
property renovated sell it
and you just opened my eyes up to lots
of different strategies and
clever ways of kind of normally down
deals and
service accommodation hmos and it just
something really clicked inside and got
me quite excited
and you had a good job and you liked
your job
yeah yeah at the same time was coming
across my book
and and seeing my youtube videos i know
you had an experience
you did a little bit of traveling to
tell me about yes it probably coincided
i think i read your book
just before christmas um a couple years
back
and then in the april following
i took a spartacle from work for a
couple of months and
went traveling around cambodia on my own
so it's quite a
brave move but
it just gave me a lot of time to think
and reflect out there done some
volunteering in a school in cambodia
spent a lot of time with families and
children there and it just massively
opened my eyes up to
i guess just different ways of living
and really got i really questioned
where true happiness comes from yeah
sure
so i came back with just a bit of a
different
outlook on life and what was important
and all all the kind of material things
i had built up
in the you know very good corporate role
i started to question
and started to really think is this the
future that you want for yourself
so i think between those two that was
probably the big
turning point and you were working as a
director for bt
so you had a good job a high paid job
and when you went when you went out
and did traveling you said that you met
people that had nothing
but you you felt that they were happy
yeah and you you went out trying to
impact them and help them
and you thought actually these guys are
really happy and you almost came back
impacted yourself which is i can relate
to that on so many levels and that's
probably why when we first met at the
crash course
there was a connection there right from
the beginning yeah i remember in that
crash course that was
uh it was about may june time and i just
remember
some of it towards the end you got up
and your values really strung through
and that just resonated with me so much
i thought you're not in it
just purely for the money there's a lot
more to you
beneath the surface and i thought i
could definitely see me kind of working
closer and getting a lot from your
yeah and we've been working together now
for the last couple of years and you
you can see you know more than anyone i
i'm a trainer
because of my mission yeah and and
passion more than anything else
um so can i just stop you there because
one thing that sticks in my mind i don't
know if you still do this
but on the crash course at the time you
handed out a yellow sheet of paper
you remember that you still do that we
do yeah right and that
that's where you basically kind of had
all your values there
and that's stuck with me ever since not
all of them i've changed them to suit me
but there's a couple of yours in there
they're still i still recite them every
day
yeah so about purpose and mission rather
than just money
so you're working money is not an issue
because you've got a good paid job
but what was it that you really wanted
then why did you come to the crash
course
why did you go on to do further training
what was the what was the strongest
reason why
there's probably a couple of reasons one
was i had a genuine interest in property
and i'd actually at that point moved
house nine times
and i thought unless i channel this
interest somewhere else i'll keep moving
house for the rest of my life
just to fulfill that kind of creative
side
so that that was one so actually i can
maybe make some money while enjoying
what i do
um but the other one was that kind of
passive income the freedom
to one day hopefully build up enough
wealth to give
back um and have that time freedom to be
doing other things and to volunteer your
time and to travel more
so there's kind of two sides and now as
well and we're going to go through the
story of how it happened but you have
quit your job
yeah so you're now full-time maybe not
even full-time in property but you've
got
you've got an income coming in from
property and and now you're spending
your time
focusing on doing what you love doing
which is helping people health
um which we'll get to talk me through
your
first deal in fact your very first deal
was one that i was very opposed to if
you remember
i thought we were going to talk about
that yeah we still we still we still
argue about this to this day
tell me about that uh yes so this
is a property um i'd saved up a lot of
money
and i decided i need to buy a property
in spain
um just because spain's nice because
yeah and
listen one day that is part of my plan
is just passive income so i can actually
spend a couple months of the year out in
spain so
there is a bit of a long-term strategy
you're still debating me now
you know you know you're wrong it wasn't
the most sensible
financial decision ever and they were
about to buy it
just just when we met yeah just as i
joined the
academy okay sure when we so when we
first started talking one-on-one yeah
yeah yeah um i think by that point i'd
probably already invested a fair bit in
fees and all the rest of it so i did put
a big deposit down
there's a lot more fees involved when
you buy in spain so there's quite a lot
of tax
um so basically that purchase went ahead
i never properly in spain
but i could have it had i listened to
your advice
i could have been financially free
probably a lot quicker with that money
yeah um and you know what though and i
said this to you at the time i said i'm
not saying it's a terrible thing and
you're an idiot to do that
it's just not the smartest from a
commercial financial
viewpoint and i told you that at the
time but i think you've kind of already
committed
so you went ahead and bought the
property in spain is it doing okay
it's not quite paying for itself
yet but i only started i mean it was for
me
personally but then i did start renting
it out probably last summer so i've
never had a full summer of it yet and
obviously
the lock time situation then you get me
back by saying yeah but samuel you
bought a range rover
exactly not every single investment has
to be
commercially savvy you can do things and
this is what i said to you i said if you
really want to do it if it's really
going to make you happy
then do it but it's just not a good
investment property
so you did that which didn't leave you
with
not a lot yeah you weren't really left
with with much money at all at that
point maybe a few thousand
um so what happened next to talk me
through that deal the
little the little um the property that
you refinanced told me because
that was such an incredible point yeah
that was a few
uh well the very first one was a rent to
essay
so that was that was you know with very
little funds i thought actually that's
something i can do
so i about two months after joining the
academy got the first rent usa deal
um that was on city center location in
newcastle
unfortunately didn't work out it was in
a
apartment block and the management
company decided that we're no longer
going to allow um essays yeah shine but
it happens
so yeah um it wasn't it wasn't really a
success in terms of the finances i did
lose money
um i questioned at that point whether it
was
right to carry on but i did
and i learned a lot from it like a lot
so the next
step of the journey i done very
different so
kind of took all those learnings into
place um
so two after that
was the first purchase so um partnered
up with somebody
um who already had a few properties and
together we put the finances together to
buy our first
um b r o um so we bought in our local
area it's uh it was one bed flat but it
had the most
humongous bathroom you've ever seen so
it was just obvious
for a two bed conversion yeah
so we bought that for forty five
thousand
got a good deal um spent in total about
eighteen thousand on it
eighteen so so far about sixty three
thousand yeah
it needed um a lot of damp proofing
throughout so it was about five thousand
on the damn proofing
um and included in that figure it was
actually my
end goal was to turn it into a serviced
accommodation
really high-end so i wanted good spec
and included in that figure was all the
furniture as well okay so we
it if you deduct that and the down proof
from it was probably about 10 grand on
the actual refurb yeah so
um so we've done that uh
that got revalued this year just in
february and it got
revalued at 90 000. that's really good
so i was really pleased
that you're over the moon yeah so we
send out all your money all the money
back out yeah wow
yeah and also that property as it's a
service to accommodation
what are the mortgage payments on that
uh
about three just over three hundred
three hundred is that interest only
yeah and you're how much are you making
i mean what you rent it or what you
what's the turnover on that well it only
went live a few weeks before the
lockdown so i'm only just starting
which we're going to get to because when
you quit your job and then it was like
oh moment um but that one
on its own i'm hoping we'll average
about
seven or eight hundred profit per month
a profit per month so the turnover on
that
will be how much i don't have a
calculator
but all you care about is profit which
is good you can't turn over his vanity
and profit is sanitary
profit first love that great so okay so
that property is going to give you after
all your costs after your mortgage
payments it's going to give you a profit
of around about seven to eight hundred
pound a month
plus it was a no money down deal because
you bought it and you pulled out all
your initial money
that's like the dream case study of a
property yeah
and i always had an exit plan if the
essay didn't work it's a really good
rental area so
standard by elect would probably make us
about 200 a month
great so even if even if it's an estate
doesn't work you're still going to be
making profit it was still no money down
deal
and the thing is with people like you i
shouldn't say that
but is this you've always had the
property bug
right you love property but the thing is
without the
financial savviness and the education
what can happen is you can end up doing
property deals that are fun and exciting
but don't really make any money like and
that's that's where
i found you were at when we first met i
thought this person
wonderful person great heart wants to do
a lot of good for people and help people
uh
working crazy hours and and everything
but what you're going to do is you're
going to save up money and you're going
to dump it into a property and you're
going to do some fun stuff with it
it's going to get the itch the property
itch but it's not going to give you any
financial freedom it's not going to give
you any passive income but what you've
done now is you're
you're now a bit much smarter investor
so
you're doing things but you're making a
good income from it um
so that property you then went a couple
more
uh yes so um have
two rent to rent deals all in the same
area that was one of the kind of
strategies i took
after the keysight uh the newcastle city
center one didn't work out is to
actually
set it up close at home so all three of
them are now within about 15 minute
drive and that that works for me to be
able to manage them
in a fabulous location aren't they yes
so
they're all coastal properties um in the
northeast and
it's a great area for families tourists
so it works really well
from service accommodation perspective i
didn't i didn't think it would initially
it was a bit of a
test um but
as well we come on to that in a second
but kind of post lock down
it's really started to pay off and do
you think as well
that rent to rent is a good strategy i
mean i mean you're somebody who was in a
high paid job you did have some money
you just invested into a property in
spain what why did you choose
rent to rent as a strategy um
initially because of the
minimum amount of money down so it is
just the refurb costs
um so it meant i could get that momentum
going quickly without any major
kind of funds behind us so i would
absolutely advocate it if you're
starting out
that is by far the way to go as long as
you've got a
good agreement in place and you get all
the terms that
are right for you i think that's
important
but i must admit longer term
it's to build up my own property
portfolio because you have the capital
appreciation benefits to go with it as
well
so basically rent to rent is a great way
to get cash flow
but if you want to build wealth you kind
of want to be investing in your own
properties
i think that's really good so let's talk
about the situation then when you got to
a point where
you had a few rent to rent properties
everything's fantastic
and you thought you know what i can now
quit my job
talk to me about how that happened and
then the holy moly moment
when you just quit your job your big
earning job
is now finished you're relying on rent
to service accommodation properties
and and some savings from the refinance
which is great
but then suddenly lockdown comes tell me
through that whole moment because it was
an interesting moment and we spoke
quite a bit about it yeah um so i hadn't
at that point
if i go back to well it was i made the
decision before
um probably around back end last year
um and at that point i wasn't covering
my
outgoings through property but i had
enough
confidence and belief that i would i was
on the right journey
and by taking the leap um out of that
secure corporate job would actually give
me free up the time to accelerate that
so i
kind of at that point through everything
i'd learned and all the support i had
i i felt confident enough to make that
leap so
i made the leap at the end of february
three weeks later somebody decided to
pronounce a bit of a lockdown
yes and with all of my eggs in a
serviced accommodation kind of tourist
market basket things just ground to a
big halt
overnight so um
thankfully i had had some savings um but
it was a kind of [ __ ] type of what do i
do now
um but do you know what though
it didn't take as long i think to kind
of pull myself
out of that situation there's no point
in being in a
kind of negative spiral it gets you know
where it was
out of anyone's control so
i just kind of looked ahead to what
i'd built up and what the future would
hold
knowing fairly confidently it would come
back
and it would bounce back and thankfully
it has and been in a coastal area in a
kind of touristy town
with three service accommodations is
actually really starting to pay off now
and also through that lockdown period i
mean you weren't losing money were you
uh yeah oh were you oh because you're
actually losing money
wow so you were really hit hard well
believe it or not um one
one property was live had been all of
last year and that one was doing okay
because it had
reviews and it had so i did still have
some kind of um key workers in
over the period the other one had just
gone live in february
so that was very new and the other one
went live
the day the lockdown was announced
pretty much it was the worst time
two of them were empty for three months
that is terrible
so there was all the outgoings all the
bills you still needed and i remember
phoning you up
because i i i knew that you were gonna
quit your job and that was always
kind of the plan i think and then in
february you quit and in february
it i mean people were there was a little
bit of talk about corona but it was
mostly in china yeah no one would have
known no
i didn't no one would have known that
corona was going to come
so badly into this country that would
have a lot it just wasn't
it wasn't part of anybody's plan at all
and you quit your job in february and
then i remember the following month
corona um really kicked off and then the
lockdown happened
and i'm just feeling awful because i
thought you know you're such a
kind person that's coming from such a
good place you've worked hard you've
built up these few properties
and yes you've got you've managed to
pull your money back out of this deal so
i knew you weren't
strapped or anything like that which is
which is fine but i just remember
thinking
oh my goodness one of my one of my
academy members
has just quit their job based on their
service accommodation business
and and now lockdown's happened and and
i've reached out and we we
i know we spoke um and you said and you
were really
sweet and positive and i thought you
might be kind of annoyed almost to be
like oh you know i've just quit and
you told me to do this so i was thinking
i need to talk to you but you were
really
calm about it and said exactly what
you're saying now which is like i'm not
going to focus on negative i know i'm
we're going to get through it and you
know so that that was really
really really good but now things have
taken a
a massive positive turn how much profit
now then not talking previously but what
sort of profit i know it's hard to say
because until
with service accommodation it varies
every month but what what what kind of
profit are you making right now as we
speak
so july was a little bit of a slow start
but
ended really strong and we've got the
three properties
of close to 85 90
occupied throughout august so
if um if i use
i mean august is going to be best case
scenario we know that it's kind of
seasonal peak
um but that would bring in probably in
the region about five thousand
profit per month um but good month
you're probably talking five grand
okay and that's profit yeah which is
actually really good yeah
and although that's not as as as much as
your job was paying you
it's still i mean between three and five
thousand pounds a month
from from three rent to rent properties
that's really good
sits yeah especially as one of them you
own yeah and you've got all the capital
appreciation with it as well
um what would what would your advice be
to somebody
wanting to go and get a rent to meet
because presumably now is not a bad time
because
assuming it's in the right area and it's
the right property how would you go
about approaching the landlords
what would be the advice that you'd give
so the first one i got was
um direct from an agent latin agent yeah
um and that went really well and i think
the reason behind that it has to it's
the strength of the relationship we have
with them
so spend some time actually going and
meet them face to face
get to understand the type of so i
approached a company
who are a local company it was a
family-run business
and i had a good idea already what i was
looking for so it was very much
kind of i help you you helped me type of
relationship and we became
quite good friends throughout it as well
so she was always looking out for me
for other properties that come along so
i think if you can just get on that
find someone where you've got that
rapport with they'll do a lot of hard
work in the ground work for you
so important i always say a good
relationship is better than a good deal
yeah
because if you've got a good
relationship with agents and landlords
you're right they'll do a lot of the
hard work for you
what's life like now then how does it
feel to be i know we've just kind of
still coming coming out of lockdown but
what's it like to not have
a job to go to uh
i always knew i wanted time freedom i
guess
i've um but actually
having it the reality of it is so much
better just being able to wake up on a
morning
and plan your own day and choose what
you do and when you want to do it and
it's given me the time to
um to set up another business i've been
looking to do it's been a bit of a hobby
but it's completely different in the
well-being
space so that's the type of thing i
envisaged when i
set off on this journey yes i'm doing
properly because i love doing property
but it's given us time freedom to start
doing some of the other things that i'm
so passionate about that
i just could never have done in a
corporate job
so it is hard and it is tough there's
lots that goes on behind the scenes of
running your own business
but it definitely all pays off yeah well
you've worked really hard and
it and it's it's now paying off because
you're now living life on your terms
which is awesome um what what was it
like talk to me a little bit about the
training because i know you did you went
through some very advanced training
what was that like how did that help
what was the experience
you know what i i i can see this and i
know a lot of people see this but this
is genuine i would not be sitting here
today with a story to tell had it not
been for that training
it's as simple as that because i might
have read a book
but like you know you said earlier i
didn't have the
strategy of how you actually take
some ideas and actually turn into a
business i think that's what was missing
so that training it opens your eyes up
to
different and new ways of doing things
it gives you the tools and the
techniques that you need
but i think even more importantly that
it gives you the
the network of people and the support
and your
kind of mentorship all the podcasts that
you put out all your winners on
wednesdays videos
the facebook group so it's it
it's a collective behind the scenes
effort if that makes sense so i think
that
access to the network it gives you and
the training
like i said i would not be sitting here
simple as that and that's great and
that's part of my mission they know
like in the same way that you love now
you're spending your time
on helping people with their well-being
and things like that because you love
doing that
um this is what i love doing i love
sitting and with people like you
and even though you're on the other side
so you've um
are part of the academy doing the
trainings come to the dinners
you also watch most of the winners
wednesday videos
yeah yeah that's been my inspiration
throughout this because i i live in the
northeast so i
i've got down to as many training
courses as i can
but when i can't get to them i need to
keep a hand in on what's going on
and that was my way of doing it so
winners on a wednesday without fail
a lot of your podcasts alistair and
russell's podcasts
um it just every time you listen to it
you'll pick up another little nugget
and it just keeps you inspired and it
keeps well for me it kept
the belief that i could do it seeing
other people do it around you
whenever you've got any self-doubt watch
one of those videos and i'm back on it
again
yeah so do you think i mean i always i
always say i think one of the reasons
that a lot of people don't
want to succeed is because they don't
have the correct education and that's
why
why i teach i think another reason as
well is also sometimes people don't have
the belief
and they don't have the the right
mindset
how important do you think having a
positive mindset and a belief in
yourself
in the system how important is that in
succeeding in business
it's i can't
express how important it is i mean you
need to learn the practical side
obviously
but if you've just got that and nothing
else well for me personally that that
wouldn't be enough
i would fail the mindset is where you
make
or break and i'm starting to understand
that even more now and i'm only
part way through the journey you've got
to have
belief in yourself you've got to for me
understanding why i'm doing it and
having those goals is what kept me going
when it got really tough
and kind of investing in yourself every
day so listening to some
i've read a lot of the books you
recommended which dog dad pure dad i had
never even heard of before i kind of
came across you so
books like that and i'll listen to those
every single morning for a good 20
minutes half an hour and getting ready
just to make sure your mind stays
that's so interesting like your story uh
you know you've done you've now got um
rent to rent properties that you've put
very little money down
making three to five thousand a month
you've quit your job it's an incredible
story
but it could have so easily been a
disaster story
not just with the with the lockdown but
prior to that so
there's so many times and when i look at
some i can often see i can see two
people
and they have the same training they
have the same one of them goes off to
succeed one of them doesn't
but the only difference is when one
person had a negative hurdle
they focused in on it and let it that
they talked himself out of it and
started dwelling in on the negative
and focusing on the problems and blaming
people
whereas whereas the other group of
people such as yourself
say yeah of course there's problems
there's always problems and you can
always find negativity if you look for
negativity you're gonna find it but if
you look for solutions and positivity
you're gonna find that as well
so when you had your um
you said that the first property in
newcastle didn't work out so you could
have just said it didn't work out
therefore the training doesn't work
samuel's not legit he
makes it all too easy and and this that
and you could have gone down that
mindset which a lot of people do
or you could say it didn't work but
that's normal
because actually yeah what did i learn
and actually part of the teaching is
to go for no and fail your way to
success
so yes it didn't work out but how can i
now use it as a stepping stone to get
success and i think
that that the difference between having
a problem or a failure and using it as a
stepping stone success
and then just starting blaming and or
blaming yourself
oh yeah some people watch windows
wednesday and they find it depressing
because they go
all these people succeeding but are not
me whereas whereas if you say actually
i'm going to be inspired by it and
do you know i think that's i think
that's so so important what do you think
100 agree i'm a lover of quartz and
freezers
but the one that sticks in my mind there
is obstacles or what you see when you
lose
track of your goal and i think that's
true because there's so many things that
will get in your way
and obstacles that will come but if you
allow them to they'll stop you
you've just got to keep focused on where
you're going why you're doing it and
you'll find a way around it
and who because i'm sure when you did
the training i'm sure there were some
people
he did the same training as anthony yeah
we won the dfe together on the dfa
yeah he's gone on to do ridiculous
things
extremely successful um and then i'm
sure there was some other people
that that didn't do anything and then
there's you who's done well
what would you what advice would you
give to somebody how do you how do you
get that
determination and that positivity is it
a choice or is there a secret behind it
to be able to just keep going to then
succeed and not
quit probably two
two things come to mind the first one is
in the beginning when i first joined the
course
i think uh i'm quite impatient so i kind
of wanted it all to happen just now and
i went a million miles an hour at it
in all sorts of different directions and
then i
kind of realized you're running yourself
into the ground for one
but you're following other people's path
you're following other people you're
seeing what other people are doing
trying to copy it
so i think i took a step back and
thought wait a minute
figure out what's right for you find out
what your strategy is which you would i
think in one of our sessions you would
recommended look it's
essays it's three stick to that
so i did and once you know what your
strategy is stick
keep clear on that because there's so
many things that can take you off down
different paths but you'll just drift
so i think get a clear strategy
and have confidence in following your
own path
don't try and copy somebody else's i
think is
yeah and that's one of the things that i
mean we do on the academy we
we get people to work out their business
plan because if you go into any business
you need a business plan for yourself
you can't if you want to set up a
franchise you can't look at mcdonald's
and then look at this and all these
different
it's like well actually what's your
business and i think in property
sometimes people i want to do lease
options and rent to rent and oh this
person did it in sheffield
i saw samuel did an ff challenge in
sheffield i'll go to sheffield and
and you're right and you can end up
becoming frantically
flustered and another thing you said
that's so important as well is almost
that tension between
patience because this is not gonna
happen really really fast
it might do if you happen to be very
very lucky or
like me when i do my financial freedom
challenges i've already got the
knowledge and the experience so sure i
can go and make it happen really fast
but when you're starting this journey
don't think of this as
a 12 day or even a 12 week thing think
of this as a 12 month plan
or or even a two or three year plan i
mean you've been now
going for a couple years but most people
if you if i said to someone how would
you feel if in
two years time you're making three to
five thousand pounds a month in
recurring income from property that go
i'd be over the moon
life-changing okay well why do you get
so upset when it doesn't happen
in three weeks you know be a bit patient
but at the same time
yes go hard yes put put the energy in it
you need massive action but you need a
little bit of patience because
when you go to university you spend 12
months at uni exactly or two years
you don't expect results until you
finish training
and then you finish training and then
you expect to start getting results but
i think sometimes when
people expect they go to a crash course
or and they expect to suddenly walk out
of the room
financially free and it's like no you're
going to get the tools and then you're
going to
implement them and you're sure you can
go into advanced training and you can
you can work on them but think of this
as a 12-month thing not a 12.
you're in training like you say the
university
you don't go to university expect to be
a doctor in three months time
you've got to put the effort in to get
there so that's kind of
where i've been over it could have maybe
happened faster but
looking back i don't think it needed to
i think it happened at the time the pace
that was right for me
and it became easier when i took the
pressure off myself
for having to you know you've got to do
this next week you've got to do it
and that's when it became easier but i
would say the other thing which is
really important
i mentioned earlier is to keep your mind
for me to keep my mindset in the right
place
that has to be a daily investment in
yourself so i spend i've got
quite a an interesting morning routine
but i'll get up really really early in
the first couple of hours on the morning
i will meditate i will read some kind of
inspiring
book i'll journal and there's lots of
things i'll do
just to set the day off in the right
right way and i think if you don't
that's when you start drifting and
doubting
and and just surround yourself with
like-minded people
and i think for me that has to become a
habit you have to do that every single
day to
to did you make friends on the academy
yeah yeah yeah um leah and cheryl
and they've also been on windows
wednesday yeah
obviously anthony and even through the
facebook
um network we've got there as well so i
had a chat with
uh peers a couple of months back and we
shared some kind of list
on wednesday's wednesday yeah so it's a
good it's a great little community
it's great as well i mean remember the
dinner that we had last year yeah
that was so good wasn't it that was
beautiful venue yeah but it's just so
nice when
that wasn't like only academy members
dinner
and it's like just looking around the
table it's like that person's
financially free that person's
financially
that person's financially free that
person's not quite but they've got two
properties and that
and it's just like i think when you're
surrounded by people
who are winning and successful and
making money in property but also
rooting for one another and care about
one another i think that kind of
positive peer pressure and support
for me i think is absolutely i know i
wouldn't be where i am
without people just around me believing
in me rooting for me
you're the makeup of the people that you
spend time with do you agree
do you agree with that 100 agree with it
i remember you said that
we're back when and it that stuck with
us that is that your five
closest yeah the people that you spent
the five people you spend the most time
with
yeah is the makeup of who you are yeah
so if you're if you're five
if the if your five closest friends are
all broke negative
whinging about life complaining then
you're getting this
off on you yeah you'll be the sixth
whereas if you if you've got five
friends and they're all financially
independent in property and they love
life and they're positive
you're going to be the sixth it's just
that's just how it's going to be
definitely
and you've just got to just become a
little bit more conscious of that it's
not to say you don't spend time with the
other people
but you just make sure you've got like
the right balance of where you're
spending your time but
um yeah and i think just being around
people in that environment
hearing their stories makes you believe
even more that you can do it
because you realize everyone we're all
just normal people at the end of the day
if they've done it and surely i can do
it i think as well what you've said
because you live
very far away i know because we're here
now which is which is where we're in
durham just yeah on the outskirts of
durham on the outskirts of durham
um and i think as well online the power
of online
is so so good and that's something we've
been talking about earlier over
breakfast
is just how great it is to be able to
utilize
online communities as well um and i
think that i mean
100 years ago we had probably horses no
cars
no planes no mobile phones no internet
now we're
so privileged to be able to drive and to
be able to pick up the phone and
be able to join an online group i think
we've maximized that it's we're very
very privileged
which is which which is great i think
it's a good opportunity it's a good time
to do business
what would be your kind of final words
of advice
to people listening people that are
thinking maybe they're in a job
and they're thinking of getting into
property what would you say to them
do it would be the obvious one but um
understand why you want to do it make
sure you've got some clear
kind of visions and goals behind why
because it will get tough at times
but if that passion and desire is strong
enough and you invest in yourself
through training through networks
through mentorship
then it will happen and one of my kind
of
one another read but that really
resonated with me is the power of
consistency
yeah so small steps every day no matter
what it is really as long as you keep
that up consistently
you will get to where you want to get to
and it doesn't matter how long it takes
you just have that belief and it will
happen
yeah that's great well i'm sure
you'll have inspired a lot of people
from this story i don't know you don't
really get anything from coming on here
apart from just to sit and share to
share your story
but that's that's really what this is
about is to just help other people
um i i've loved working with you over
the last
couple years um and and hopefully
you have too yeah honestly i know i said
it earlier but i
genuinely can't thank you enough for
just your words of wisdom the support
that you give and i know you do it from
a good place as well and like i said i
wouldn't be sitting i really appreciate
that and it's an
absolute honor um to have been able to
work with you
and to see you continue to flourish as
you grow your business and you grow your
portfolio and you help a lot of people
in health
so um thanks so much for coming on the
show and we'll look forward to seeing
what happens over the next few months
and years yep
thank you very much i think you would
agree that nicola is just a fantastic
person and deserves every success that
she's got if you want to see more
interviews
it's really interesting because every
week i interview someone from a
different background different walk of
life
so if you want to see the whole playlist
of winners on a wednesday
you can check that out right here also
please don't forget to subscribe
turn the notification bell on you can do
that right here and drop a comment
some support and some encouragement for
nicola i'm sure she'll read the comments
thanks so much i'll see you next time